[Music]
the secrets of the X chromosome these
women are identical twins they have the
same nose the same hair color the same
eye color but this one is colorblind for
green light and this one isn't how is
that possible the answer lies in their
genes for humans the genetic information
that determines our physical traits is
stored in 23 pairs of chromosomes in the
nucleus of every cell these chromosomes
are made up of proteins and long coiled
strands of DNA segments of DNA called
genes tell the cell to build specific
proteins which control its identity and
function for every chromosome pair one
comes from each biological parent in 22
of these pairs the chromosomes contain
the same set of genes but may have
different versions of those genes the
differences arrived from mutations which
are changes to the genetic sequence that
may have occurred many generations ago
some of those changes have no effect
some cause diseases and some lead to
advantageous adaptations the result of
having two versions of each gene is that
you display a combination of your
biological parents traits
but the 23rd pair is unique and that's
the secret behind the one colorblind
twin this pair called the x and y
chromosomes influences your biological
sex most women have two X chromosomes
while most men have one X and one Y the
Y chromosome contains genes for male
development and fertility the X
chromosome on the other hand contains
important genes for things other than
sex determination or reproduction like
nervous system development skeletal
muscle function and the receptors in the
eyes that detect green light biological
males with an X Y chromosome pair only
get one copy of all these X chromosome
genes so the human body has evolved to
function without duplicates but that
creates a problem for people with two x
chromosomes if both X chromosomes
produced proteins as is normal in other
chromosomes development of the embryo
would be completely impaired the
solution is X inactivation this happens
early in development when an embryo with
two x chromosomes is just a ball of
cells each cell in activates one x
chromosome there's a certain degree of
randomness to this process one cell may
inactivate the X chromosome from one
parent and another the chromosome from
the other parent the inactive X shrivels
into a clump called a bar body and goes
silent almost none of its genes order
proteins to be made when these early
cells divide each passes on its X
inactivation so some clusters of cells
Express the maternal x chromosome while
others Express the paternal x if these
chromosomes carried different traits
those differences will show up in the
cells this is why calico cats have
patches one X had a gene for orange fur
and the other had a gene for black fur
the pattern of the coat reveals which
one stayed active where
now we can explain our colorblind twin
both sisters inherited one mutant copy
of the green receptor gene and one
normally functioning copy the embryo
split into twins before X inactivation
so each twin ended up with a different
inactivation pattern in one the X
chromosome with the normal gene was
turned off in the cells that eventually
became eyes without those genetic
instructions she now can't sense green
light and is colorblind
disorders that are associated with
mutations of X chromosome genes like
color blindness or hemophilia are often
less severe in individuals with two X
chromosomes that's because in someone
with one normal and one mutant copy of
the gene only some of their cells would
be affected by the mutation the severity
of the disorder depends on which X got
turned off and where those cells were on
the other hand all the cells in someone
with only one X chromosome can only
express the mutant copy of the gene if
that's what they inherited there are
still unresolved questions about X
inactivation like how some genes on the
X chromosome escaped inactivation and y
inactivation isn't always random what we
do know is that this mechanism is one of
the many ways that genes alone don't
tell our whole story
you
[Music]